الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله ان عمليه
الاستهداف جاءت بعد رفض طاقم السفينه
الاستجابه لنداءات القوات البحريه اليمنيه
بما في ذلك الرسائل التحذيريه الناريه ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد استمرارها في
منع السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله من الملاحه في
البحرين الاحمر والعربي حتى ادخال ما
يحتاجه اخواننا في قطاع غزه من غذاء ودواء
ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد استمرار
حركه الملاحه في البحرين الاحمر والعربي
الى كافه الوجهات حول العالم باستثناء
موانئ فلسطين المحتله كما تؤكد القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه ان اي اعتداء امريكي لن
يمر دون رد او عقاب وتحذر القوه الوات
المسلحه اليمنيه العدو الامريكي او غيره
من اي اعتداء او اجراء يمثل حمايه للسفن
التجاريه التي تذهب الى الكيان الصهيوني
كما اننا في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه نقدم
التهنئه والعزاء للاخوه المجاهدين في حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس في استشهاد
المجاهد القيادي صالح العاروري رفاقه
الشهداء صنعاء الحادي وال من جماد الاخره
1445 للهجره الموافق للثالث من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه